avoir deux
[Musique]
elle regarde et seconde à l'égard ouais
c'est frais il ya un problème
à bord
[Musique]
c'est où le fera désormais sur le frein
c'est pas une automatique certains des
années 60 a amerri fou et 55 je sais
bien
[Musique]
fra
moi mon quartier j'avais juste un prévu
de rentrer je veux revanche comme ça
j'arrive pas à me faire branché dû à la
peur
goûter tel sourire oui caliente comme si
le temps s'était arrêté neuf non cotées
sur toi sécurisé y avait dans le séjour
on n'en veut ni en 1 8 kg 5 de pression
chaque attaque plus sa place dans
l'autre
[Rires]
ouais passe à vegas reste à vegas que tu
vis plutôt un blank et pourtant mais bon
tout aussi de pajot à neuf pour moi non
alors moi le bonheur divin c'est d'avoir
du temps pour regarder la télévision
dans la chambre blanche le petit
douaniers rouquin manhattan où il ya un
bonnet ricains lé ga ga qui me faire un
plan bape est l'autre vous sourit de
monsieur m photographier qui sa taille
même si j'ai reconnu la classe même à
vegas on me reconnaît et je viens juste
d'arriver
toi qui fais n'importe quoi derrière
commence à m'énerver
est ce qu'on fait on s'arrête on camille
bien aidé par cyril faut l'avouer à une
super idée la meilleure idée des 15
dernières années y piquer cléda voiture
de mathieu bélie ce en attendant je
reviens tu restes là
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chère madame
[Rires]
tintin
[Musique]
et
ça
attendez
ça a démarré très très bien et dégage
sur les bras côté un truc je vous jure
ici il y avait une équipe américaine au
bout de vingt minutes ils ont dit on ne
travaille plus avec eux je vous jure
c'est vrai moi
c'est vrai je pose et la dépose et
pourtant c'est quand même l'équipe qui
bosse avec les kardashian carré ils ont
voulu poser des caméras ils ont dit on
arrête tellement visite alors isabelle
vous ne savez pas conduire on l'a vu ici
donc je vous ai dit c'est là c'est
l'avenue principale de las vegas c'est
la guerre je vous le dis c'est la folie
nous on est en fous rires ont fait le
tour on enfouit et il ya un membre de
l'équipe qui va lui venir en aide à et
vous allez voir de qui s'agit quelqu'un
qui ne devait pas partir et qui est
parti finalement regarder
[Musique]
ils appellent pour série le ciridd pour
isabelle oui là comme ça et il mélange
noir chic alors isabelle j'ai dit oui
j'avais alors me répond pas isabelle
sais pas comment ça marche
oui
c'est un facteur
celle que j'ai connue cette année de
faire un bras d'honneur elle connaît qu
elle avait qui réactive abbas et b nay
qui conduit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle est géniale cette fois lors elle
faisait partie de l'équipe américaine
vous est venu on est donc voilà mr merci
à elle à elle elle était au bout du
rouleau york c'est vrai alors voilà
voilà
regardez ces tests elle s'appelait scala
et la whey très sympa c'était là il a
une petite aventure avec elle on a fait
des brasseurs en fait merci je vois que
vous savez mettre la femme à l'honneur
[Musique]